Where were Ant-man and the Wasps?
Did you see them? I didn't see them.
Where was "Tic-Tac"?
Good question.
No, I mean, really I have no idea.
I mean, I don't remember being asked to be in their movie.
Just saying ..
Maybe they were on their way, but they went subatomic.
Maybe they were there
but they were pretty tiny and there were definitely some ants in Wakanda, so ...
Maybe they're in the same place of Hawkeye.
Gamora, Thor
Spider-man
I was
really looking forward to meeting the Wasp.
Yeah. No, not there.
Weird.
I just have one question
When Cap needed help
If I'd asked you would you've come?
I guess we'll never know
But if you had you'd've never been caught
I do some dumb things and the people I love the most they pay the price
Thanks to you we had to run
We're still running. Let's go.
Maybe you just need someone watching your back, like a partner
Hold on, you gave her wings
and blasters
So I take it you didn't have that tech available for me
No, I did